ضجه على المنصات في تونس بسبب ظاهره غريبه
رصدوها الناس في الضواحي الجنوبيه للعاصمه
التونسيه وهي التغير لون مياه البحر الى
الاخضر
ولا عينيه
[موسيقى]
الله اعلم
الفيديو اللي شفتيه متداول بشكل كبير جدا
على المنصات والناس بتقول انه السبب في
تغير لون البحر للاخضر والروائح الكريهه
اللي جايه منه هو التلوث اللي من فتره
بتشهده شواطئ المنطقه اللي تحولت لمصب
لمياه الصرف الصحي ومو صالحه للسباحه
واعتبروا موت السلحفاه البحريه اللي
موجوده على الشاطئ دليل جديد على التلوث
البيئي وتلوث مياه البحر والاتهامات هذه
ردت عليها وزاره الفلاحه والصيد البحري
بانه في فريق راح من الوزاره على المكان
وعمل معاينه واخذوا عينه من مياه البحر
والوزاره اطمنت ان التلوث مو السبب في
الوزاره قالت انه التحاليل المجهريه بينت
ان السبب في تحول مياه البحر للون الاخضر
هو تكاثر هائل للطحالب الدقيقه اللي
معروفه باسم ازهار العوالق النباتيه وهي
غير سامه وقال البيان انه هذه الظاهره
طبيعيه وبتصير عشان تغني البيئه البحريه
بالمغذيات واسباب تزايد التكاثر الطحالب
بيكون زياده درجات الحراره والاحتباس
الحراري احنا عملنا بحثنا وطلع فعلا في
ظاهره مثل كده في العالم وفي مسطحات مائيه
كثيره تم رصد تحول مياهها للون الاخضر
بسبب الطحالب وفي بعض الاحيان بتكون طحالب
ضاره
[موسيقى]